Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing in the seventh chapter,
the chapter of
authored by
we mentioned Thursday morning
that
is certainty. It's usually translated as
certainty.
However, al in the Arabic language is a
certainty that is so strong,
so assured, so unremittent, so unshaken
that
no percentage
and no amount of doubt can displace it.
Al
is the highest levels of knowledge, the
highest levels of belief.
And for this reason, Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
uses this word in the Quran to refer to
those things which are most certain and
usually most unanimous
with respect to human belief.
is one of the greatest acts of worship
anyone can
worship Allah with. As a matter of fact,
it's an act of worship that is
necessary. It's one of the necessary
components and it is one of the most
important stages a person will
arrive at on his journey to Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
What is a we have to be able to quantify
it and we mentioned
is a type of worship. All of these are
types of worship
is also a type of worship. It's worship
of the heart.
And how do we quantify it? What are the
pillars of a every act of worship has
conditions? Every act of worship has
pillars.
And so how do we quantify it? What have
the scholars of Islam told us about
what goes into
what is the difference between a person
who is
and a person who is not?
could
literally translate to
placing the utmost of trust in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
in the fulfillment
of
and in the fulfillment of a person's
desired outcome. This is called
tawakul
and it has two pillars.
The first pillar
and these pillars go together.
Any of these two pillars is not is
missing. It is not
the first pillar
is
and the second pillar is
subhanahu
I would I would something to
happen. I have a desired outcome in mind
and so I set out to obtain this outcome.
There are two pillars to this. The first
pillar
is that I do whatever physical means
necessary to
obtain that outcome.
When we say whatever physical means
necessary,
obviously we're not speaking about halal
and haram. We're speaking about,
you know, that which only can occur
because of these certain things. If I
don't want my enem swords to pierce my
skin, I wear armor, right? If I want to
have children, I get married. If I
do not
if I am sick because of some poison I
stop taking the poison I take the
antidote etc. This is
so I do whatever physical means
necessary
that would bring about that desired
outcome. The second isallah
is is that I
completely put my
trust in Allah. Meaning I have a
level of certainty
that this will only come about
by way of Allah and that Allah will
bring it about
and that Allah will bring it about.
So those are two things
a person
wishes to go into battle. We look at the
prophet sallall.aii Wasam how he teaches
us.
He says,
he says,
Allah subhanah,
Allah subh, the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam tells us that
if
we were to place our trust in Allah
as
we did
as he is right to he would
bestow upon us that desired outcome
as he does the the birds even that just
go out in the morning hungry and come
home satisfied.
And so when a person
wishes to have something fulfilled,
they look at the way that the birds go
about
in their
in their in their
pursuit of sustenance. They don't just
hang out in the tree and, you know, just
wait for it to start raining worms down.
No, we even have idioms. And
I I I know in Arabic and English, but
I'm sure in many other languages,
we have truisms
that look to the behavior of birds. The
early bird gets the worm.
Because birds are set on a schedule.
They are very disciplined in obtaining
what they are, what they are seeking.
And so the prophet sallallah.aihi
am. He says
that if you all were to rely
on Allah as he is rightful,
he would bless you and give you as he
does the birds.
that you go out in the morning
the the birds they leave their nests
hungry and they come home filled with
their bellies filled.
So these are two pillars.
Number one, that a person do whatever
needs to be done
of physical means. Right?
And number two,
that a person not rely and his trust not
be in those physical means. That that is
just a a physical means. It's like
playing the game by the rules. That's
all you're doing. you're going through
the motions and you're doing what Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has
you're going about things in the way
that Allah has intended when he created
cause and effect. So you undertake those
causes.
You undertake those causes
but your reliance is upon Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Now some scholars
they add a third pillar and they say
that a person
have
much certainty and reliance in Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. The person is
certain that Allah will bring this thing
about
or is certain of the outcome that Allah
brings about.
However,
[Silence]
And so we always remember these two
these two pillars and in order for us
to undertake anything as human beings we
have to have a le a level of faith in
that thing
for instance I'll give you an
example a scientist
looks in his microscope
and studies
some kind of
some kind of virus
trying to figure out a cure for this
virus or bacteria or whatever.
Now, what would cause this man
to spend hundreds and hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds of hours
studying this virus?
There's only one thing that drives him
and that is the belief
that this puzzle can be solved.
If he doesn't believe that there is a
cure, he won't try.
Even if he
is unsure if there's a cure, maybe there
is, maybe there isn't, he would not try.
We would not have the willpower to
undertake such a tedious
path and journey.
There is inherently a level of belief
when a person undertakes
the physical means to a particular
intended goal or intended outcome.
a person who you know and which is why
it is so ironic when you look at you
know so-called scientists, biologists or
astrologicists
etc. when they try to when they are
simultaneously trying to learn about the
universe but disbelieve in its creator
because how do how do you know that it's
not just random? How do you know there's
a method behind this madness? That there
is a harmony behind it? What makes you
so sure there is a discovery to be made?
Maybe things just are the way they are
superficially and that's it. Don't make
it more than that. There is no bigger
answer. There is no undiscovered
molecule. There is no but we don't have
this belief. The belief inherently is
there is an answer to the question.
Therefore, I continue to pursue the
question.
This is
when a when the Muslim has in Allah,
he is not placing his trust or he is not
placing his sights on the physical
means.
Rather the disbeliever may do the same
thing and undertake the physical means
but the belief is in the physical means
itself.
No, the Muslim does that physical thing
and
his reliance and his in Allah subhanahu
wa'ta'ala. That is the difference.
And do not think that a Muslim is not in
danger
of placing his trust in the physical
world rather than in Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala himself.
Have you ever met a Muslim
who allows himself to become debased
in order to earn a dollar?
Yeah, you have.
What has happened here? the physical or
the trust has shifted from trust in
Allah to trust in the physical means to
the point that they feel that if they do
not continue to have access to these
physical means they will no longer have
have access to the bounty of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
and the people of the book before
that the
Jews in Medina
were fighting against the prophet
sallall.aii Wasam
thinking that their their fortresses
were going to protect them.
Allah
that they thought that
their fortress was going to keep them
safe from Allah himself.
How could you think that? How could they
think that? They're they're people of
the book because
if you were to ask them, they would say,
"No, no, no. Our trust is in Allah." But
when you watch the action,
the action tells a different story.
So the Muslim is in danger of not
having his trust be in Allah, but his
trust be in other than Allah.
[Arabic recitation]